People, when they say, "You're an inspiration,"...
...they mean it as a compliment.
They mean it as a compliment.
And I know why it happens.
It's because of the lie,...
...it's because we've been sold this lie that disability makes you exceptional.
And it honestly doesn't.
And I know what you're thinking.
You know, I'm up here bagging out inspiration, and you're thinking,...
..."Jeez, Stella, aren't you inspired sometimes by some things?"
And the thing is, I am.
I learn from other disabled people all the time.
I really wanna live in a world where disability is not the exception, but the norm.
I want to live in a world where a 15-year-old girl sitting in her bedroom...
...watching "Buffy the Vampire Slayer"...
...isn't referred to as achieving anything because she's doing it sitting down.
I wanna live in a world where we don't have such low expectations of disabled people...
...that we are congratulated for getting out of bed...
...and remembering our own names in the morning.
I wanna live in a world where we value genuine achievement for disabled people.
And I wanna live in a world where a kid in year 11 in a Melbourne high school...
...is not one bit surprised that his new teacher is a wheelchair user.
Disability doesn't make you exceptional,...
...but questioning what you think you know about it does.
Thank you.